dea
僕は今別府湾を望む消えカフェに来ている
大分で訪れた喫茶との中でここが一番好きだ
安いから美味しいから別府湾の眺めが素晴らしいからという理由ではなく
多いとで訪れたカフェは他にスターバックスしかないからであるという団が区内尾いた
途端
カフェインの効き目が薄れているのに気付き激しいと
お気軽ねぇ放送コーヒーを1杯飲んで30分が経った頃には次々と文が出てくるのに
対してそのに3時間後つまりカフェインの効き目が薄れ始めてこの頃には稀でかわいい
女の子と初めてレストランでテーブルを挟んで座った時のように頭の中に用意していた
笑をすべてをされてしまう
何を書けばいいんだろうと考えているうちに
窓の外で雨が降り出す雨がザーザー降っているという誰でも描けるような表現はできる
だけ避けた方がいいと確かに小説を書きたい人のための本に書いたと僕はそれを読んだ
ときに安心した
なぜかって外国人と適温事期待511覚えるのがつつもなくめんどくさいかれたよ
もっと個性のある文章を書いてみる
そういうふうに書いた後それを読んでから僕は雨の描写に気を付けるようになった
そしてこの間スターバックスで村上隆のしキティ内による窓の外には細かい銀の針の
ような雨が降っているという表現に出会ったときにやはりプロは違うぬフォトもず
つぶやき
その辺の女子高生をビックリさせてしまった雨のざざー降っている
そう言わずに
大雨が降っているという状況どうやって読者に伝えたらいいのか
まだの外を眺めながら頭を働かせ始めると同時にここまで意味不明だったこの文書の
タイトルがやっと意味を持つようになるほどわけのわからないゲームが使わずに雨が
降っているということとそれに対する非者である僕の絶望的な気持ちや皮肉っぽく表現
できた自分に幹部する力そのようなボレーはという
に m を言われに恐怖に取って代わられる隣に座りテーブルにビーフカリーをこぼし
ている中年男が
まじまじと僕のパソコン見つめているのだ
と声をあげてしまいそうになった僕は反射的に itunes を開き適当に曲を変え
たり音量を上げたり絞ったりし始めるしばらく僕は何もかけない僕にできるのはこのと
か観察することだけだ
いかにも田舎のお菓子屋さんで480円で売っていそうなイチゴののったパフェが
テーブルに運ばれる中寝ようと彼はそれを目の前にすると笑みをわかる
おもちゃみたい
の小さなフォークを手にするそれを見ると僕は心が痛くなって仕方がなくなり
思わず彼に声をかける待て男が口に運ぶ途中のパフェ落としそうになりウット前を開け
てこっちを向く
食べないでくれ配当と後一瞬怒りの表情を見せる
おそらくこの外国人は警報使いこなせないだろうと思い出したのか笑顔を作る
何ですかそのパフェ食べないでくれ
なぜですかあなたがピンク色のシャツを着てい
ハゲあがったとか何なんですかあなたはピンク色のシャツを着ていて頭がハゲあがって
て大まかに夜中が出ているそのパフェを食べてしまったら残ります彼の男らしさを失っ
てしまう俺はそれが見たくないんだという喫茶店で男の人がパフェやチョコレート
ケーキを食べてるのを見るたびに反射的にいいだしてしまいそうな言葉この文書に入れ
たら面白いかもしれないなと思い
依存秒迷ってから
書くことに中年男は484しそうなイチゴパフェを一つ舌で
女々しすぎてこのシミする覚えるけれど禿げ上がったピンクのシャツを着た中年男が
パフェを食べることで僕の読者払うかもしれないそう思いながら何も言わず窓の外に
視線をスレッドはの穏やかな水面が日光を反射しているという文を書き気持ちが高揚
する
雨がやんだっていう言葉を使わずにすむ意味が通る文章たった40分で思いついた事業
の天才だと思えてくるしか使えたらまたバイクを磨かなきゃと思うとうぬぼれはすぐに
憂鬱に変わる
バイクてくるべきじゃなかったん
[音楽]
me